[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 35 of
GameSpot after dark or is as I'm keeping
track here now part three of the work
from home edition my name is Jake Decker
I'm your host joining me this week is
Lucy James hello Kelly plaguey hi and
joining us this week a special guest Ben
Hansen founder of min/max hello hello
thanks for having me everybody of course
how you doing real good I'm in the
freezing cold min/max studio here in
Minnesota but I've been a fan for a long
time like this is you know GameSpot it
is my favorite video gaming site going
back to back when I was video games calm
I stumbled across it when learning how
to use the internet so I'm so happy to
finally be on it in a way here is this
your first time like everyone a GameSpot
thing I think it is I was really
thinking about it well like I guess I've
been on the beast cast but that barely
counts right that part of the live from
CBS family okay all right I guess yeah
and I was on CSI once but that's not
important
thank you for having me on
anyway we start this show off with the
well normally we started off with what
we've been playing but this week we are
going to start with the Chris from
Dayton Ohio segment although it's gonna
be a little shorter I don't have all the
questions in front of me so we're gonna
keep it simple we're gonna go back to
our roots and we gotta do the theme song
oh yeah the theme song I haven't heard
that in a while
but anyway Ben yeah it's just a bit is
you're gonna you just tell us what you
do what you like to do what games you
like to play just a little bit about
yourself whatever you feel like telling
us what about games if you want okay
that's no I like talking about games yes
so uh hi I'm Ben Hansen I'm in Minnesota
I'm from Minnesota it's an odd place to
cover games but I love it here it's a
my favorite place to live and so I was
at Game Informer
I started a game former in 2010 as like
the first video producer the first
full-time person working on video and so
I eventually went on to like host the
podcast at Game Informer but also while
there like the very fun part was I went
on basically every cover story trip so I
ended up going on 80 cover story trip so
I was like spending two days at studios
filming interviews and stuff and like on
that monthly magazine rotation who's
super fun and then towards the end of
last year there are some layoffs of Game
Informer that were pretty brutal and so
I decided to leave and found something
called min max here which is really just
a studio in my basement but it's a
patreon so I gathered together some of
the former Game Informer folks that were
laid off and now we have a whole network
about games friends and getting better
as we put it nice congrats on that it's
been it's been fun to watch you guys
build up that community and whatnot
seems like you got a really good group
of people who are sticking to you guys
and following you oh man yeah it is
absurd like the whole idea of like oh
yeah I guess you know at the lowest tier
the patreon we can have access to like a
discord that'll be a fine thing that
seems like a thing to do and it has been
the most important thing like just
having that sense of community and also
when it's behind a paywall even though
it's like such a small paywall but just
like even a $1 $2 pay wall it just like
cuts out so much of the noise on the
internet and everyone is just so sweet
and supportive and a really interesting
thing has happened to we're like since
we said min max was an overall thing
overall site about games friends are
getting better like having that self
improvement angle has just like lent
this positivity towards the entire
community that's been really fantastic
and so yeah the community I am in love
with them they are so great and so like
we do big game Club discussions it's
kind of like seems like the thing that
the community is most excited about
where we have what we call the best most
thorough discussion about games on the
Internet
which i think is true because like we
just wrapped up a big game Club for
Chrono Trigger which we call the deepest
dive by the way and on that one it was
six hours of us going as in-depth as
possible but current rigor along with
like hundreds of people playing and
sending in comments and then we filter
those down to like the best of the best
and so it just it gets so specific and
so fun and it's really fun to like
tear a game apart in a positive way and
so we're doing one an animal crossing
right now and we have the Final Fantasy
7 remake coming up very soon and finally
7 is my favorite game of all time so I
cannot wait to just get as detailed as
possible with the community on that
thing
dang that's really cool I've never
played Chrono Trigger Tamura keeps
telling me to play it all the time I
know I need to play one of these days
and I got it on DS because tomorrow told
me that that was a good version to get
but I don't have my D s with me so I
can't play it now would be the perfect
time to write ok honestly just get it on
Steam I know when it came out everyone
was like oh it's terrible and it was
when it launched they have quietly
patched it to a place now it's like it's
totally fine like just play that version
the font is a little bit screwy at times
but just for the ease like it's a great
version at this point and it holds up
surprisingly well like I love the game
but we had two people on the game Club
it was their first time playing through
it and they're both like this is
fantastic it's amazing it just like cuts
out a lot of BS from old JRPGs it's it's
just the good stuff yeah I definitely
want to check it out I remember buying
it on Steam when it first came out but
then I looked on Reddit and everyone was
like this is the worst port ever so it's
like yeah I'm gonna refund this and play
it play it differently but it's good
they they fixed it up yeah you can just
buy it again after your refund which is
a fun cycle for money
before we move on though I gotta ask you
started put you on the spot do you've
any yeah on Mike McCarty yeah let's see
hmm
yeah so he was an intern at Game
Informer back in the day we just
actually had an interview with him min
max talking about like a Simon the
industry overall and stuff and I was
trying to crack that that shale a little
bit cuz he has such a tough tone you
know like some people are a little put
off by his tone like I don't know
exactly what's going on in that head of
his cuz he kind of has an odd one but
okay try to think of dirt I'm thinking
of like Mike's oh man because I've known
Mike for years and years we used to
freelance at the same time it
yeah yeah obviously no mic for years and
yeah you really you're like why is going
on in your head he'll just say something
you're like oh oh did not expect that
one take a bite out of the banana skin
and all in a coffee cup yeah good times
I was so let's see I was trying to find
like an old Halloween photo to try and
remember like what costume I went is is
the year before or something so I went
to Google photos around last Halloween
and just typed in Halloween and it
popped up a bunch of just de betras
pictures of Mike and I from years ago at
a Halloween party here in Minnesota
whereas like I was dressed as like this
spooky Slenderman and I think he was
like Wayne from Wayne's World try to
remember who know he was Marty McFly or
something but it was just like a lot of
like basically almost making out shots
just drunk and blur like I don't
remember this is a weird thing to have
in my phone but that is the Mike my
heart in my mind now is him trying to
make out with Slenderman world like he
went without a Garth here let's see how
it goes and you were that girl for him
that's right spiritual Garth yes he's a
dear friend and a sweet guy
anyway Cali how's the animal crossing
come along it you know I've got great
news our store is finally upgrading so
talked about that last week and how it
was actually driving me to the brink and
yesterday Isabelle made the announcement
that business was booming looks granny
was gonna get updated took 33 days I
have no idea what the requirement is I'm
asking everybody because like we're good
working on a lot of guides and I want to
get this information I've been like
consulting with different people like
who have had their store upgrade and I'm
here in 28 days I'm hearing 70,000 bells
spent I'm hearing all these things well
I spent like way above seventy thousand
bells and it was 33 days for me so maybe
there's something that we don't know
but that guide comes out April 9th and I
did buy it so there's that but it's by
day now the bunny wolf April 12th is
actually bunny day which is animal
Crossing's version of Easter in the
Japanese they just call it Easter and
it's like it's kind of funny to me
because it's really like a [ __ ] up
take on Easter with like a horrible
rabbit like fright five nights at
freddys ass he comes starting on April
1st at least this year it's like a
rolling they have kind of like a live
game ongoing game approach to New
Horizons so this year it's April 1st
through 12th you can find eggs all over
your island and craft them and the
horrible bunny will give you rewards it
reminds me of that episode of Futurama
where they have robot Santa and everyone
hates him and is terrified of him and
like pulls all their blinds down so the
robot Santa that's what that bunny
reminds me of true did you see that a
Twitter video that was being sent around
where like somebody using the camera
mode was looking at zipper T Bunny as
he's dancing around and doing his usual
zipper T bunny stuff and then like
walked away and it turns out like when
you're out of frame and far away from
Super T bunny then he's like and he
likes eyes and just like relax is
basically just lights a cigarette
not really but like he just completely
turns off his character which is such a
fun detail that how would they think of
that yeah like I would love the
creatures like takes his mask off and
it's just like Tom Nook I I saw that
before I saw the Twitter video I saw it
because I was trying to take like creepy
photos of seperti bunny because he was
standing behind one of my trees and I
wanted him to look like a serial killer
so I was taking one or two photos as you
do remote yeah and very own brand I
think and I walked out of frame and then
he did that you like side and just like
went like he like he kind of just is
like alright cool they're not onto me
anymore like that's really weird I don't
like it
anyway that's going on I'm looking
forward to the Earth Day event seeing
what happens with Leif the lovely sloth
who's very happy also I have a villager
in my town that Jake really wanted it
was like the only villager that you
wanted Jay and Jay and he told me today
that he wants to move out so I'm letting
him move out and hopefully he'll go to
Jake's town I think you can one view
later be cool yeah once they're packing
up their boxes I'm almost positive you
can like it Jake can come to my town and
like talk him into moving to his Island
really see this is the fun part about
Animal Crossing right now though is the
fact that you're like I'm almost
positive that's what I love about Animal
Crossing is it's all it just feels like
word-of-mouth like I think this is what
is triggering this for me I don't know
it feels like we're all back on the
schoolyard it's such a fun vibe oh yeah
I'm having a great time I mean I'm not
having a good time from I have to write
guides perspective on it not knowing
things they had a great time talking to
people and being like oh like this fruit
still rot can you try it for me like
this happen in your town because this
thing happened and so we're going to
find out tomorrow if Jake can actually
steal this villager from you basically
now you just crossed yeah Lucy how about
you you've been playing some new DLC so
I love to control control was one of my
favorite games of last year I was super
excited for foundation to come out and
then I started to play foundation and I
realized I remembered that I've just
completely forgotten how to play control
it also didn't it didn't help that I
started to play and when you boot up the
DLC it unmapped the service weapon and
removes all your mods I think it just
must be like a bug but I saw a couple of
people say that on Twitter and I was
like oh yeah that would that help
wouldn't it but you have to like just
read it doesn't like a race that you
just like captain which is you it in
your inventory yeah but it but I didn't
realize that in the first combat
encounter like wait is this a part of
the DLC I've just like lost all my
powers or something you know I just
didn't have my weapon
but it's it's super I mean control is
one of the most confident it's one of
those confident games I think I've ever
played in terms of its tone its
aesthetic its style
and honestly I just even though it's
been a while since I've played any of it
I think the last time I played some
control was October last year I was just
spending time like levitating around and
using throw and just chucking stuff
launched sorry and just throwing rocks
at people because it's just it just
feels so good foundation itself it's
tough but I think part of that was just
me being out of practice
totally but it's so good and now that
I'm playing it it has photo mode that I
keep I just keep getting distracted but
it's it's great I love control yeah it's
got just a cool look to because it's
like you're underneath the oldest house
at the foundation of it of course and so
like all the ground is like cool red
sand and stuff at least like the
starting areas which is the only area
that I've played so far it looks sweet
it's so good is it don't get into
specifics because I don't spoil anything
but is it answering some questions that
were lingering from the end of control
I'm looking forward to playing it yeah
but like I haven't played the other DLC
so far just because as fun as that game
was the play right I I'm waiting for
story especially Alan Wake stuff this is
um I want to say that it will answer
questions right now it's just presenting
me with more but in a really cool way I
think like the main sort of storytelling
thread that you're following is one of
the characters who you meet in the main
campaign Marshall I believe has gone
missing and you're trying to track it
down and that's why you go to the
foundation and it's like even though I'm
down there and I have both of the new
powers now so one of them lets you it's
not really so much a power it's just
breakable environment so you can sort of
break holes in the ground if enemies
there are new enemies and they are tough
but you can break holes in the ground so
that they'll fall through them and the
other one is you can pull these sort of
mineral you can either pull them into
spikes or pull them onto new platforms
to traverse over so you can kind of get
to
places so I have those but story-wise
I'm still very much in the dark mm-hmm
how's the checkpointing it's better yeah
but I think I think there's just more of
them yeah and the area that it puts you
in in the foundation itself it's very
much
you know like you'll do an area and you
there's a centralized area and then
you'll go off and do a section of it and
then you'll unlock a little pathway back
and you know it just feels like it's a
lot more open I'm not doing as much fast
travel anymore it's and checkpointing
wise because there was a section where I
was dying a lot but the checkpoint was
really good yeah and they also like
redesigned the map a little bit to make
it easier to read it's pretty subtle but
they have like a blue tint now so you
can you have a better idea of like
what's an upper level what's an or lower
level because that's definitely my main
complaint about the main game as I spend
so much time looking at that map like
what where am I supposed to be going in
it was a shockingly detail with map in
some ways yeah I agree but then I kind
of found that I was overcompensating by
looking at the signs in the game which I
kind of enjoyed doing more I was like
okay I need to go to research I need to
go to this section I'll just follow this
sign and hopefully it'll be through
there yeah yeah or not I didn't use the
map for most of the game I would say I
was just following that and then I found
the map and I think I opened it and I
was like no this is this is not helping
but occasionally you get to the point
where it would be like alright I got to
use the map and then I'd sit there and
stare at it for a long time while I
tried to figure out where I was where I
needed to go how different corridors
overlapped or didn't overlap but yeah
that games good I'm excited to come back
to it yeah I can't wait I mean I'm
taking my things I'm waiting because I'm
playing Animal Crossing but I'm excited
you can wait for necessary things like
talking as if RT bunny just control um I
guess I'll talk about what I've been
playing before we get to you Ben cuz you
observing an exciting new game that all
of us have played yet yeah well no
newest yeah yes new in a sense uh-huh I
guess for my half-life update I finished
all the half
games except for Alex I'm still halfway
through Alex I finished episode 1 & 2 I
think last time we did this I just
finished half-life 2 for the first time
moving and then I moved quickly on to
episode 1 in episode 2 finished both
those I really liked episode 2 I thought
it was great
my favorite part about it though is
actually not in the game I was looking
up a guide just to get some of the
collectables and at the very end of the
guide it said we'll see you in half-life
2 episode 3 and it was like on a game
facts guide from like 2004 whenever and
I was like heartbreaking yeah if you had
to if you had to rank the half-life's if
you say that like episode an episode
episode 1 & 2 are like their own game
entries how would you rank everything
you've played so far that's tough
because I liked episode 2 a lot more
than I liked episode 1 but I think I
think half-life 1 to be fair I didn't
play half-life when I played Black Mesa
oh no that's my think I think that was
my favorite one and then I would
probably say the episodes and then
half-life 2 like I've said before I did
end up really liking half-life 2 but I
think I just played it too late like a
lot of the impressive technical design
and stuff like that was just kind of
lost on me because it's I mean it's
still impressive but it doesn't have
that same effect as it did and what
2003-2004 that said though I really
enjoyed them I'm very excited to go back
in and finish Alex because I made it
about half way and I was told I should
stop and see how the other games ended
but I'm in the process of upgrading my
PC because it was having a lot of
trouble playing Alex so I'm gonna wait
for that and then hopefully next week or
maybe the week after I can give my final
thoughts rank all the half-life games
did you have a chance to play Alex Ben
no I watched serial Vasquez we streamed
like the first hour and a half here at
min Max and I get nauseated really
easily and so I was having a tough time
watching him and so's like okay I can't
even play it but maybe I'll try it again
and watch like Daniel Dwyers like it
sounds a personal Channel but he has
like a full walkthrough where he's going
through the game so I tried watching
that again and like I
I can't it makes me to six so I then
have just listened to a bunch of spoiler
casts about it and it sounds great yeah
I mean Greg has a survived index and
vive is always historically been the
headset that I've had the least amount
of trouble with so I am tempted but at
the same time part of me is like oh if I
go through all the hassle of setting it
up again and and I feel sick is that I
mean to be fair I've not got much else
going on so I could just just load up on
Dramamine and you might be able to blast
away through it yeah
good I think there's a mod now where you
can just play it all with mouse and
keyboard it's ready yeah I thought I saw
someone on Twitter being like here's how
you can play with mouse and keyboard it
probably doesn't work very well because
it seems a little too quick but give it
time right I bet you like sure I've
played that game and it's definitely
meant to be played in VR but if you
can't get through VR and someone has a
mod to play that mouse and keyboard and
you really like half-life I think it's
probably totally worth doing because
some of the story beats I've seen so far
are really cool it'll definitely won't
feel as tense or exciting as I'm sure it
would be because like you know in
half-life 2 alone you've probably fight
more head crack or more zombies in one
level than you do in the entirety of
half-life Alex but like still apparently
that story in that ending is is worth it
so yeah and you know it - it seems very
cool I'm happy for half-life fans anyway
and then apart from that I played a bit
of the modern warfare 2 remaster and man
that game like goes off the rails so
fast I forgot like like yeah I guess in
a good way but like the first level in
that game is already way more bombastic
and ridiculous than any level in modern
warfare 1 like I don't know if you
remember I didn't remembered I had
completely forgotten it but you go
through this town you blow up this
bridge you go through this town in a
tank and all these buildings are
collapsing and I think Marines shout
hoorah at least 50 or 60 times
throughout them the 10-minute level and
like it is it is absolutely absurd that
that game came from what was modern
warfare 1 not sit at modern warfare 1
wasn't ridiculous and bombastic but they
were definitely in the sequel mentality
I guess with that back in 2009 yeah I
mean I love Marta Morpher wanted it I
mean they literally let's stay frosty is
a big thing in that game they do that
all that [ __ ] but I have a lot of
nostalgia for modern warfare 1 I feel
like my memory of modern warfare 2 is
just only no Russian like I just really
have very little that sticks out to me
whereas like modern warfare 1 there was
so much that like you know like all
gilead up in mile-high club and even
like the nuke going off my warfare 2 is
just like the the no russian discourse
and that's it so I I mean I am curious
what people's take on no Russian is
especially like now but I also am like
maybe I should buy that game again can
we not do that and I kind of want to
just play the game again and try to
remember like yeah I have I haven't seen
like the hot take squad out there for no
Russian yet maybe I'm just not on
Twitter as much as I should be our
people writing the big thing pieces
about this thing again I think I saw one
okay but for the most part I don't think
I've seen it which I'm kind of thankful
for I was like we already did this in
2009 I think it's written the right way
it's still worth doing but yeah I'm not
looking forward to like Twitter thread
and like I would rather read a whole
piece about it than like totally six
different people's Twitter threads know
his way no Russian is probably Mike to
be one of question mark it's like this
I've been here well you can't buy the
campaign in Russia
apparently I mean it makes sense but
yeah it's unavailable in Russia at least
what this is what I saw on Twitter so
maybe it's not true but I would 100%
believe it that's interesting yeah I
mean Russia had problems with it
originally so mm-hmm and then they're
also pissed about the remake or new
version of modern warfare about like
Mo's at that the bridge of death or
whatever that exact area was right right
so maybe there's still some ill will
over that saga I will say I definitely
like recommend revisiting modern warfare
2 if if you've got a PlayStation 4 and
if you've got $20 to burn because it is
it is interesting it feels like a very
different game I don't think it's aged
now I guess to be fair I haven't
finished it I've only played the first
couple missions but I don't think it's
aged nearly as well as modern warfare
part of that might be due to the fact
that I think they spent a lot more time
on that modern warfare remaster than
they have with the modern warfare 2
remaster I don't know that for certain
but just the I I'm getting that vibe so
far whether or not it's true I don't
know but it is interesting I think
modern warfare 2 has a lot of great set
pieces but it just it really lacks the
subtlety that made I think Modern
Warfare's campaign kind of more than the
sum of its parts I'd say that's Horton
Shaw and who's been playing the remaster
and we were just kind of talk about how
Call of Duty stories like outside of
some standouts or have kind of devolved
or have been and not to vault cuz it's
been that way for a while including
modern warfare 2 it's either like we
were gonna make this about PTSD and then
we decided not to or the good guys had
to do some bad things but they're still
good ok with some like insanity in there
both both kinds like black ops also has
its crazy weird stuff but those are like
the two flavors of Call of Duty story
that you get hmm and I think that's
another thing having played the modern
warfare masters
recently is like I don't know that game
is not like a masterpiece of
storytelling or anything but I think it
had like it really did try in ways that
some other Call of Duty games did not
totally one thing I will add just really
quick is the I think I've actually
talked about it before but the infinite
warfare campaign gets a lot of [ __ ]
because people hated infinite warfare
but that campaign is really good it's
the one that do you remember when the
yeah that's the one that I didn't play
because I'm yeah most people didn't play
it cuz you to it was the most disliked
video on YouTube for I think it still is
oh yeah and it came out with the modern
warfare remaster so most people just
play the modern worker cry yes but the
campaign was like really good because it
was all one shot like you'd start the
game on earth and then you get into a
spaceship and then you'd fly to your
base and then you'd go into your base
and you'd interact with different crew
members you'd pick different missions on
a map and then you'd go down to your
hangar getting your ship fly to the
mission do the mission get back in your
ship and fly back it was all seems it
was really cool and I like I get why
Infinity Ward didn't want to continue to
pursue that because the fans are really
mad about it but I thought that game was
pretty cool you know it's no press f to
pay respects not that's true anyway Ben
what have you been up to
oh hey I don't know so last night I
finished resin evil 3 and just the
remake yeah and I am fascinated by the
reception of that game it is all over
the place and it's it's so fascinating
so GameSpot it's like a review in
progress right now is that right it
actually should be by the time this goes
up it'll be final okay okay but it was
still on the lower end of the spectrum
from what I saw oh yeah it's a it's a
six it is a six okay gotcha yeah I I
really enjoyed
time with it it's such a weird thing
because I think a lot of people talking
about it are gonna naturally compare it
to the present evil to remake which last
year was min Max's game of the year for
2019 we really loved it here and so when
you're talking about wasn't evil threes
remake it's just a lot of talking about
the negatives and it's important I think
to zoom out and just like big-picture I
had a really great time playing this
game
I enjoyed it maybe 70% as much as I
enjoy going through resonable too but
like that 30% is just a lot of like well
then this then this and this and I know
a lot of hardcore resonable fans are a
little bit upset that like they're
removing some of the replayability and
they've stripped out some big things
that were in the original like key
locations and stuff like that but like I
played that original game you know over
20 years ago I remember fighting some
sort of worms in a graveyard something
like that you know so I'm not that
annoyed if big chunks are missing I
don't really notice it as much so I had
a really great time with it like what's
everybody looking forward to at this
remake like what's your best case
scenario for playing this thing I I mean
I really liked Resident Evil 2 remake as
well and I just kind of want more of
that I would say yeah I've also resin
evil 3 is the only one I actually
haven't finished resin evil one but
resin evil 3 is the only one I haven't
started or played at all over the
mainline series so I just kind of want
to play it to see what happens but I
don't know I like the resin evil remake
to a lot so I'm excited yeah I think
you'll have a good time with it like it
really it moves maybe it moves too fast
like there's definitely moments of what
is happening with this story and I know
the writing is never spectacular in
Resident Evil games but when this were
in particular it's like by the time
things are wrapping up I don't really
know who these characters are I've
barely interacted with them it and it
just it um it dials up the action much
more than Resident Evil 2's remake and
it's tough when talking about that
because it's like oh it's inching back
into that kind of like resonable 5
territory but it's not it is not
Resident Evil 6 you know is not to that
level yet it's just like starting to
maybe think about going back in that
direction and a lot of fans I think are
going to be a little bit upset about
that overall
but if you're looking for like you know
if you're not big on replaying Resident
Evil games and you just want a fun
experience that is very similar to
reasonable twos remake I think you'll
have a great time with it like I
finished it in six and a half hours I
know some people are complaining that it
might be a little bit short and you know
not different scenarios and stuff like
that but maybe it's just cuz I enjoyed
having just a shorter experience and
also then at the same time I'm a
notorious coward like where's evil -
just terrified me and I realized like I
was 3/4 away a few rows evil 3 I was
like I haven't really been scared yet
like this is this is a good sign I think
for what I want from games is that like
ok it's not that terrifying it's intense
when nemesis comes out but it doesn't
freak me out the way that you know a
licker would and reasonable to flipside
of taking because it could it could also
be the you could have the alien
isolation problem in that if that game
was ten hours it would have been perfect
and it was like the perfect level of
intensity and horror but it was
stretched out - I think when I played it
was like 20-something hours and by the
end I was like oh it just keeps going
yeah so like I can understand the people
who are happy that it's short because it
feels like there's always a discourse
about all games are so long these days
right right and maybe if you know you're
not into the original resistance
multiplayer mode and stuff like that
like it seems like a good game for like
once it goes on sale you know five
months from now you'll pick it up and
have us all the time with it but on the
nemesis front obviously he's the star of
the show here and a big complaint is
that he's a lot less dynamic than he was
in the original so it's a little more
set PC and he just pops out at the same
times every time but again if you're
playing through that once like you will
still your heart will race when he pops
out you know like I'm not big for set
pieces overall even like Call of Duty
like I play all those campaigns and I
enjoy them but at the same time I'm
never like yeah oh my god the explosions
or anything but like everytime nemesis
popped out it was like okay here
Rico you know cold sweat as I'm just
trying to get around the corner trying
to dodge zombies on my way to somewhere
safe so he's still intense even if he's
maybe not as interesting as a lot of
people were hoping cuz a lot of people
were hoping based on mr. X and his evil
2's remake that oh my god imagine that
but blown up to a whole game and that's
what resonable 3's nemesis could be it
is not an expansion on mr. X it's almost
a dialing back of what people liked
about mr. axe that's something that
Alessandra mentioned in his review too
right Kelly yeah there were a couple
things you touched on that but
Alessandra did talk about in his review
like the set-piece moments and like kind
of how that that was a little jarring to
him like and obviously I don't want to
speak for him but having edited his
review he talked about like you kind of
get swept up by the story taking you
from location to location and you don't
really get to like sit with anything too
long yeah so that the the brevity of the
game like I like short names cuz I like
completing things that [ __ ] makes me
feel accomplished but he was just
talking about how like by the time you
get used to a place you know you gotta
go and the characters like you there's
just there's something there was
something not quite right about that to
him yes I totally respect that yeah it
is an odd feeling and I was thinking
about like what why does it feel like
it's moving so fast I think it's a small
thing and maybe not character focused
but there really aren't puzzles in it
it's pretty bizarre how much they've
stripped out on that front so there's
not much of like going through the files
reading things not too much of like
rotating objects like basically is like
okay you're gonna be doing a lot of
lock-picking picking up a lot of keys
and just slowly working your way through
it but it turns out when you remove that
puzzle aspect from Resident Evil game it
just you feel like you're studying your
environment and really soaking in each
roman moment a little bit less yeah I
think I i'll serenity ville 2 remake was
my first Resident Evil game which is
weird because my brother is
super into resident evil he's played all
of them I just like never I don't know I
run into it and I liked being scared
there's footage of me screaming at
lickers
there's a lot of fun and so I I would
rather have that I like things in that
sense that are slower paced and less
action focused where I get to feel that
tension and not be stressed out about
like it's it's weird I know being scared
and being stressed are very similar
emotions but they're distinct to me so
I'm excited to play exciters definitely
gonna play it and I'm with my family
right now so I'll be able to like at
least watch him play it and and see how
he likes it and see if it's something
I'd be interested in but I'm not sure
that the action focus is exactly what
I'd be looking for
so yeah it's also significantly easier
than there isn't evil to remake like if
you're a resonable fan I would recommend
playing on a harder difficulty out of
the gate because playing it on normal I
am not good at games in general resin
evil in particular and so playing
through it I was even like man I have
more than enough ammo at all times I
really I mean I have so many herbs
sitting around and first-aid sprays that
I never used it's really really generous
and it kind of gets away from that
beauty of the resident will to remake I
feel like where it felt like every room
was oh my god I'm out of ammo
I'm effed I don't know how this is gonna
work okay I found one more bullet great
now I can get by and there's not really
that tight sense of like the perfect
balance of desperation like there wasn't
reasonable to have you have you had a
chance to play the multiplayer at all I
just like the just the tutorial so yeah
I guess it's probably they have the beta
which I know had problems launching on
PlayStation 4 but i think its up on xbox
and Steam right now and so maybe the
review build was separate from that cuz
I was waiting for a while for a lobby to
fill on Steam and it wasn't happening
that's what we were waiting for for the
review in progress and it's okay now
yeah oh we're there any takeaways there
that
as interesting ideas but it's pretty
clunky that it doesn't the the controls
don't feel super responsive according to
Alessandro it sounds like like he said
like in its best moments especially when
you're playing as the mastermind because
it's an asymmetrical multiplayer sort of
deal so if you're like the one player
that gets to be evil he said in his
review that there's moments that makes
it feel like a real time strategy take
on survival horror and like cause or it
speaks but that it's brought down a lot
by the clunkiness of the gameplay it's
definitely an interesting one because it
seems to still be in beta but the all
the monetization is live obviously you
can buy it it's part of the resident
evil 3 package that's why it qualified
for review for us because we did that
with warzone as well ecology warzone is
technically in beta but it's ostensibly
a complete game and all the monetization
is live so we did that with resistance
as well so maybe that's something that
like it has the potential to get better
is kind of the gist that I'm hearing I
talked to my friend max Scoville about
it and he was all excited about Resident
Evil 3 as well he said he had a good
time so yeah it's a yeah that multiplier
but it definitely feels like something
that years from now there's gonna be a
strange fan base out there like you know
what was actually cool was that weird no
thing that they bundled with resin evil
3 like that was awesome and but like
somebody wrote into the mid Mexico
podcast this week asking like what why
didn't they just make a left 4 dead
style thing it seems like people are so
hungry for that you just take the
resident items and enemies in there like
not that Oh
bing-bang-boom piece of cake Capcom but
like that formula it would have been a
perfect fit for this and to go for the
asymmetrical thing it's it's funky it's
cool I just don't know it's if it's
gonna have as much of an audience yeah
it asymmetrical multiplayer is kind of
like having a weird moment I feel like I
played predator the weekend which was so
much fun it's like it's the perfect
amount of janky point there was a
point where I was playing as a soldier
and I got stuck in the environment I got
stuck in the base of a tree and we had
to we were it was all five of us playing
were on party chat so we had to sort of
enter into this agreement with I think
come on who was playing as the predator
but it was like because there's no
there's no friendly fire so we had to
enter into an agreement with the
predator that they would come and kill
me and then they would go away in the
opposite direction for like 20 seconds
and then come back once I had been
raised by my teeth you've got it was a
lot of fun I'll go back to my starting
point yeah one two a little bit - it
feels kind of like a ps3 level shooter
it's a weird level of quality on that
thing but I guess you have a group of
friends rolling with it it could be a
good time yeah we we were lucky because
I think my roommate was trying to play -
and he just couldn't get into it took
him forever to get into matches was
because we were rolling as a 5 you know
we were we were just going straight away
and it was a lot of fun okay then we
didn't play for that long we went back
to watch very quickly yeah I do want to
try that out because I got if anything
it reminded me a lot of like that by
daylight and the Friday the 13th game
and as janky and buggy as those games
were when I played them it was still
just fun to mess around with friends in
yeah hey Dora I was thinking about the
reson evil 3 and then also I was
thinking about it again when I finished
Kakarot the Dragon Ball game earlier
this year is like I think we need to be
more appreciative that QuickTime events
have just basically gone away like those
two games in particular seems like they
should have been packed with QuickTime
events 0 it is stunning that that is
just gone feel like there was such a big
outcry about them quietly went away we
need to appreciate if I would have
noticed if you hadn't said anything but
you're right I'm trying to think of like
the last game I played with QuickTime
event god of war those were like
debatable QuickTime events for 2018 yeah
days gone
oh okay yeah stays good but yeah it's
nice that we've moved on and the nice
thing too is like yeah it's fine
you don't feel more or less engaged it
turns out they were basically overblown
you know it's like it's not necessary to
mash on the a button to feel more
connected to Goku script like struggles
or you got it you get the idea just
Randy I don't think so yeah just it's
like it's one of those things that just
quietly fades away like I can't even
really yeah anyway sorry JB I was gonna
say should we move on to news topics
yeah yes can I start with some important
news yes for it the Pokemon world
championships were canceled they were
they are as far as I know supposed to be
in London in 2021 and any points that
players accrued over the season so far
are gonna roll over into that which
means plenty more time for me to get
ready for my competitive debut doing
pretty well aren't you quite took
because I animal crossing I've been
taking a break as an animal crossing but
I I I feel like the first step was
getting like an encyclopedia of
knowledge I did that now I have to
practice but I bring it up partially
because Jake and I got to hang out with
you Ben yeah championships last year in
Washington DC and I missed the World
Championships and I was so looking
forward to going especially because I
haven't been to London in many many
years and so I was excited to see like
friends like willpotter who would go for
the trading card game he's the one who
sent me the news and obviously like yes
it should be cancelled due to the
circumstances but this is like the first
event that I've been actually pretty sad
about being cancelled so overreach
besides e3 okay
I was said about you 32 but III is also
all Pokemon World Championships are work
too but yeah I I just wanted to bring
that up
if you are interested in playing the
World Championships please check out the
guide videos that Jake and I made about
how to do it yeah please do because
those were very thorough and they need
more views maybe just open up a monitor
and play them on we can make it new
let's play series here at min/max we'll
just watch the YouTube video over well I
mean I guess speaking on things getting
cancelled QuakeCon has been cancelled
which was scheduled for August 6 and 9th
and also Bethesda cancelled its e3
showcase I'm surprised they waited till
now to do that I thought I figured they
just cancelled it with e3 but I was
scrolling through our news feed today
and saw that Pete Hines did it on April
Fool's Day that's when I don't even
think of that
oh god we're reporting gonna get for a
full day yeah he's like this stuff going
on like shroud posted today that he's
gonna go pro and violent the riot
shooter and I'm like is this a joke I
genuinely can't tell anymore no cuz he
could go pro and violent and it would be
great yeah that was really poor fools
day I was really banking on people just
not doing April Fool's Day this year
just kind of ignoring it I liked the
blizzard one the overwatch one I'm just
saying that because I'm a huge overall
trend but the over which one was good
and the G thing seems silly and fun
what was the G one hoped I'd like a
special event where it's all like I
haven't checked it out but I definitely
want to stream it at some point but it's
all like D&D characters on the island
it's like this whole twist of fun game
yeah Oh Jake we gotta bring the boys
back together return of pub G I think
it's time I think it's probably time
absolutely
but the mezda stuff it's understandable
but I'm like I just want to know more
about what okay you know working on was
it close no more about starfield two on
starfield
I was the interesting thing about the e3
showcase is that there's would have been
digital and the justification at least
from what I saw was that it was
cancelled because of like the it would
be hard to prepare it not that because
it it wouldn't be like a physical thing
yeah um sorry that's well just so just
uh figuring out the realities of game
development from home yeah like I think
that's what took so long like you know
at first when III was canceled we were
still not like quite sure how serious it
was gonna be how long we were going to
be remote I mean we weren't remote at
the time like I bet it's like oh it's
digital we can work it out and then the
longer it goes on it's like you know
what I don't know this man work yeah we
just need to see you know whatever
Sony's doing or if Microsoft will try
and scoop up some of or any of
Bethesda's reveals for for whatever they
present during e3 but yeah it's well ii
think is like Kotaku had that story
while ago about how Warner Brothers was
gonna have their first ever press
conference at e3 this year - and
something I wonder what are we gonna do
are they gonna abandon his whole thing -
we're just knowing what Rock Steady's
doing just anything please release a
trailer you cowards it's been years
you started teasing that game was the
October last year yeah yeah it was a
long time ago
the Montreal yeah the Montreal games
start teasing last year on the Batman
anniversary and then um oh what's the
guy's name snyder Scott Snyder Scott
Snyder I wanted to say Zack Snyder I was
like no that's a that too is good
tonight I'd like quote sweet it and he
was like oh yeah cool fouling it
happened again no she'll be back soon on
my back yes your back okay good I just
was I was just complaining that you know
it's court of owls it has to be or at
least that in it at some point I just
need to know I just need a new Batman
game I think the only thing that I want
right now is for Rocksteady and or wanna
Montreal to just tell me what they're
doing my brother has been replaying
Arkham City out of desperation not that
playing Arkham City is a desperate act
just like you need some nom yeah I saw
Tim Moore's Kevin Conroy thing right no
oh my god
two more got Kevin Conroy the voice of
Batman if if you're not aware two on
cameo to record a thing for him because
you know how to Mars goof is that he
always talks about it when it's his
birthday on Twitter and his birthday oh
yeah we had Kevin Conroy
he had Batman back him up and it's
legitimately the coolest thing okay hang
on what is this what is this can be like
he did so cameo is an app where
celebrities you can pay celebrities to
give you shout outs to more gave Kevin
Conroy money and you give them a script
to so I'll dig it out I'll send it into
this this chat layer we can maybe link
it in the podcast notes but I got he's
got a Batman backing him up that's
amazing have to like agree to read the
thing but like the actor who plays like
Arthur Morgan I just didn't say Rob
white off but that's Mark Clark
something Raj o'clock class is he read
one on cameo that was like like trans
rights it was like about how like yeah
it was Frode trans people and everyone
was like Arthur Morgan supports trans
right yeah I think that would work out
yeah that no it fit the Lord okay right
yeah absolutely sure before we move on I
should say that I didn't actually make
it that far and news stories
I got about like a day and a half in and
I was like there's too many new stories
I'm gonna leave it at this so there are
definitely some things here missing one
thing I don't have on here though is
that all the stuff about gear box I
don't know if we get into that so Callie
when you said I'm gonna start off with
something big I was like oh we didn't
Pitchford chat okay
let's get the tea out mom yeah so Wow I
ignore his existence as much as I was a
trending topic on my Twitter yeah he
still is I mean for some background
right was a lot of gearbox employees
were promised like six-figure bonuses
five figure bonuses and all this kind of
stuff after Borderlands 3 shipped and
then they announced today that they
weren't doing that
Kotaku wrote up about it some sources
told them which is rough and then the
other part was that upon the beginning
of the development of Borderlands 3
apparently pitchford took a was it 12
million 16 million dollar payout a large
from Allah big old bonus has shown yeah
oh sorry go ahead
oh no I was gonna say that in the huge
em one of the really sad things is like
the developers obviously went through
crunch to get the game out there was an
engine change in the middle of
development it was a hard long
protracted development cycle the game
sold incredibly well but they would
promise these bonuses according to the
Kotaku Peas and you know that's what
that was getting them through and now
it's because explanation from pitchford
apparently in this meeting was like well
we've expanded we have the Montreal
studio now I think they expanded some
other place as well and so we kind of
needed for the business overall has
pitchford tweeted about it though that
looked before noon and I didn't see
anything I I'd be surprised if he hasn't
said something about it yeah okay it
something must have put him in a
straitjacket to make him not tweet about
this yet I mean yes a lot of restraint
for that guy last thing he retweeted was
about golden keys okay yes a green man
he hasn't tweeted in 24 hours he hasn't
tweeted since that hmm well if you want
to you can support Jordan remains piece
on GameSpot about the problematic
aspects of the Lovecraft thing in
Borderlands 3 DLC because I think that
people
like to be racist about his opinion on
that so it would be nice to get some
nice positive voices on that piece hmm
if the guns love and tentacles dlc and
it's yeah
sounds pretty problematic so yeah I have
just another clear voice haven't we stop
playing the other day and honestly like
I was playing in a group and I wasn't
listening to the game at all which you
know it's par for the course with me and
Borderlands so my reading reading
Jordan's piece I'm like kind of glad no
yeah my understanding is that the the
plot of the game is that there's two gay
black men and one of them needs to turn
into a straight white man out of for
purity reasons and then the that's like
the antagonist goal but the game doesn't
in like interrogate that at all huh
that's rough
switch remasters of super mario 6 ma
really save the day hell yeah
any of those so what I even played
galaxy I never had Nintendo like I
didn't have a Nintendo 64 when I was
growing up or anything like that the
only Nintendo I had was I had a gameboy
color and the only thing I played on it
exclusively was pokemon red pokemon
yellow and The Mummy Returns good I also
had alone in the dock nice well done
that's it super the super exciting it is
that natural thing of the game industry
of like I wish this just hit me out of
left field in a direct at some point of
like this coming to switch this coming
to switch but equally exciting today I
guess to open that present right decided
to play galaxy for the first time sorry
Jake
oh I was just say as weird that we
didn't they didn't put that in the
direct at all I also didn't believe it
at first because it was like reports
they're saying that this is coming to to
switch and I was like well reports have
been saying that
gonna get the Metroid Prime trilogy on
sniffing it's coming it's government C
but no this is super exciting cuz like
Callie I've never even played galaxy in
everyone so that's one of the best but I
can't imagine it being better than Super
Mario Sunshine that's right there's my
stance wait okay you're smiling you know
what you're saying right now there's
fascinating stuff though just trying to
figure out like how they're going to
port some of those games like galaxies
and particulars like okay it's doable
but I'm trying to remember like you go
into little star launcher and I think
you shake the Wiimote to like launch
yourself out and like I'm not a fan of
waggle controls in general but like that
was strangely satisfying so hopefully
they just really pack a lot of Rumble
into this thing just more HD Rumble and
you can imagine to launch yourself out
of that star to have some of the same
effect and if you have a switch light a
little bit but yeah so it's gonna be
like this big celebration of Mario so I
guess Mario's anniversary is in
September for the Japanese release so I
don't know if they're just gonna dump it
all on that day or trickle it out but
then they also said in these Eurogamer
and BGC reports that a new paper mario
is coming this year which is very
exciting to hear I'm ready for another
paper mario game oh sure thousand-year
door like absolutely well this is the
exciting thing is kinda forget who it
was there was somebody on Twitter some
trustworthy sleuth a while ago that was
talking about how Nintendo was gonna
release the new Paper Mario this year
and that apparently it's kind of like a
return to its RPG roots and getting away
from you know the less the less than
great entries over the last 10 years or
so but going back to like that thousand
year door formula which is this perfect
yeah it was good man I think this is
gonna be a big year for Nintendo with
all these Mario games and then already
been a big yeah that's a big year but
like and the the rumors that they're
gonna surprise drop Zelda at the end of
the year too are kind of getting more
Zelda breath of the wild - which is like
when people first started talking about
I was like now that can't happen but as
you know going on it's been kind of like
yeah I could see that actually happening
which would be
exciting I mean we don't know anything
this is just speculation but uh okay
make the call though I think Giant Bomb
talked about this maybe like a year ago
on the bomb cast but do you think they
will call this all stars - do you think
they'll be so bold as to make this all
bundled together and just go in that go
in that retro route that'd be fun
wouldn't it oh just like so all the 3d
stuff and they just call it Super Mario
all-stars - fun angle if they want it
yeah would be they could have it it's
theirs do it do the fun thing
I wonder if it depends on how like crazy
the remasters are gonna be you know like
if they're remasters are just more ports
because if they're like if they redo
them like I don't know from head to toe
I could see them just doing full price
games for each of them but maybe if they
are just remastered they'll be like here
they are our all-stars - yeah maybe so
fun to see Mario 64 in odyssey's engine
I mean they started - total there's that
one level at least that looks so great
so well they were inching that direction
so maybe in the last three years they've
been working hard at it
fingers crossed yeah for a while there
you could have played Super Mario 64 in
dreams
at least part of it maybe that's why
yeah anyway speaking of Nintendo switch
the switch prices surged due to a
shortage turns out a lot of people are
trying to order a Nintendo switches
right now because they don't have a lot
to do and unfortunately a lot of places
are sold out and I saw some prices going
up to like $400 $380 for Nintendo
switches which is insane yeah gonna
change my I bought a clear case for it
the atomic purple case and I was gonna
change it and then all this happened and
I went I'm not gonna do that in case I
mess it up because if I like if I could
play am i crossing from bed yeah I've
got a pro controller that's fine but my
favorite thing is to like have it on my
desk as I'm working and sort of check my
turnip prices and I won't be able to do
that because and break my controllers so
yeah that sucks especially sucks when
people sort of take advantage of the
situation and like so I've seen I'm more
than a few tweets of people just
stockpiling them and then price gouging
yeah yeah yeah
did you see that um slight tangent but
not really like the New York Times
article where it's like hey you should
be playing video games yeah okay we know
but you know been trying to tell you for
years
yeah yeah yeah I hope it's actually
helpful I hope they like explained that
hey if you use discord or screen sharing
like you can play jack box remotely like
that I hope they give like some good
strategies in it at least yeah it has
been a has been wild to see the
conversation change from video games are
harmful to video games can help you in
this time of need it's like video games
have been helping people and their times
of need for years now the World Health
Organization was like to play video
games like there's an article from like
last year where it's like video game
editions real that's like I don't I
don't down that like you I don't doubt
that point why you are indicative video
games but overall they are massively
helpful to people yeah like you can get
everything like people get addicted to
other things that generally people
aren't shitty about so I would say most
addiction to my phone oh yeah anything
yeah 100%
yeah like yet you know that's fine yeah
not doctors we're not doctors but I did
do my dissertation in the video game
addiction but alright you actually did
psychology nothing anyway before we get
on to listener questions one last thing
I do want to mention is final fantasy 7
is shipping early in some regions on
purpose but square it sent out a tweet
being like hey please don't spoil this
for anyone I mean I would say if you're
excited for Final Fantasy 7 and you're
not getting that game early
like I just I don't know I don't to say
avoid the internet right now but you
know like be very careful when you
scroll in the comment section line up
muted words yeah line up those muted
words like I got part of half-life Alex
spoiled for me because there's a youtube
video that was like here's what happens
at the end and it showed a picture
that's more than I would ever want to
see thank you I remember the name of the
channel but I'm not gonna say it I'm not
gonna call him out right here but I was
I was bummed now I'll say after you you
won't be surprised at all saying about I
know that people are just saying hey
square I push the button on digital but
I do wonder there must be more steps for
them to follow than just being able to
push it live right yeah I believe so
because I know like even just generating
codes ahead of time that is not like a
simple process for companies to do like
even to just give the US codes like
there's even a financial element to that
so and you know there's deals with
publishers and agreements and you know
advertised changing a nice to say
available now like yeah I mean all of
that it's not that simple yeah on the
other spoiler front to my worst fear and
I think it's probably the cases I think
Square has spoiled the hell out of this
thing on their own to like maybe because
I've been paying yeah it paying too much
attention to the trail trailers and
studying them and dissecting them too
much but it's for those things we're
like putting all the trailers and all
the clips that I've seen together at
this point it's like I think we've seen
almost everything in this game maybe
they'll save like one twist in there
somewhere but I mean I think we've seen
like the last shot of the game even like
it's pretty thorough because they've
been trying to ring marketing out of
this thing for five years at this point
you know I think I think that game's
gonna be very short like not not like
six hours like Resident Evil lengths
right but I think that game's gonna be
like under twenty hours maybe to finish
part one and then you're gonna be
waiting for part two part three and then
in a couple years from now on the next
generation of consoles it'll be like
here's the full package at full length
which kind of makes sense because it
seems like the detail they are going for
that would be really hard to like put
all of that into 160
our game but I imagine the budget for
this game is massive I can't imagine
yeah I mean I love it what I played at
the demo is just perfect I'm so excited
for it but I I worry though I hate being
negative but I worried that like they
will try and Pat it out a little bit
from the sequences that we've seen by
just doing kind of like fetch quests or
like everyone so I see those glimpses of
like just walking around Midgar and
doing side quests and delivering
packages for kids and it's like oh no is
this how they're gonna kind of stretch
out that that running clock a little bit
so I'm worried about that a little bit
yeah well anyway Lucy do you want to
take the first question here Oh actually
hold on before you get into it if you
have questions for us email us at after
our podcast at gamespot.com or we have
just put up our discord server and so
far it has been great if you want in
please email at us
tweet at us whatever it might be just
get ahold of us and we'll get you in
there as soon as possible a couple of
these questions are actually from the
discord server so if you have questions
and you want to see it right away you
can just drop it in a yeah join our just
grow sir we have a channel right there
for listener questions anyway go ahead
so this is from Triceratops on discord
who says most people are now in
isolation I'm wondering what to do at
that time somewhere out there there was
someone who has never ever played a
video game and has now got the urge to
change their entire lives blow their
minds and play a game so my question is
what game or games would you suggest for
first time gamer to get them through
these shy 'test
of days who and we'll try it it's
spelled straightest I just love saying
shite
it's really good I mean Animal Crossing
is just on the top everybody's mind but
it's such a perfect choice like you know
for a game club we have so many people
right in talking about how like oh I've
been trying to get my wife or even like
my kids into video games for years and
years and years and finally it took with
Animal Crossing new horizons and there's
something about just there's not a
threat it's all just relaxed the camera
is not a hassle at all you know it's
just perfect for an entry point but
maybe somebody would jump in and be like
this is stupid what are these animals
doing what am I supposed to do how do I
win so maybe maybe it's not the best
yeah I mean you have to take into
account
person that you're recommending it to so
like I really want to try to get my mom
to play Animal Crossing I keep showing
her like Twitter photos of like peoples
cute rooms because she likes house
decorating I can do an animal crossing
but I think like there's options for
people who like you know if yep somebody
who's like really into like like if
they're really into like story based
things up books is what that would be if
you're not talking about a video game
books or movies then maybe like you
could choose like something like you
know I don't like to say this but in the
walking simulator vein that's an
approachable thing for people to play it
kind of gets people acquainted with
video game controls and then you know
they're familiar with how stories are
told already and so a really interesting
narrative can pull people through even
if they're intimidated by the mechanics
of something I wonder I wonder if the
walking simulator thing though like that
first-person like controlling that
camera I think would be a lot for
somebody you know so what are parents
both play video games so I've like never
had to deal with this well we
crowd-sourced an article on the
editorial side that was like games to
play with people who don't play video
games and I was like I have never had to
do this cuz like my mom doesn't really
play a lot of games anymore but she's
the one who like top like played a
buncha games with me so it's like
getting heard of playing Animal Crossing
is more just convincing her that she has
time to do it than anything else so yeah
really
you know she really liked brain age cuz
there was Sudoku maybe there's something
there yeah new brain age is not out in
the u.s. though so that's only for those
of us yeah um I I remember talking about
this last year on the podcast but Erica
because it's designed specifically for
people who don't play games but because
you're playing it on your phone like the
first thing it has you do is flip open a
lighter and light it but because you
know what that motion is in real life
it's really easy for you to do it in the
game and you don't have to kind of deal
with the video game
language I guess of walking your
character around it's like super things
yeah I mean there is like barrier to
entry is you need to have a PlayStation
before yeah that's tough I think if you
have figured out like video conferencing
with your family or with people that
don't play video games I do think a jack
box games are the best and Jack box
party pack 3 is still I think the
strongest out of that out of that batch
with quip lash and then TKO or draw file
2 is fantastic and I mean the jack box
team has just been giving it away at
this point is on sale and switch for
like 6 cents it's just absurd
it was so good it's so fun or if you
want like something more focused and
single-player for these folks who don't
play games like on the story front even
something like Florence on mobile might
be an interesting choice it's nice short
and simple and then if you're into a
more systemic stuff just get threes just
introduce threes to somebody I think
it'll take over their mind
I play threes every day I play it every
day and I have to like years wait threes
yeah oh my god that's amazing ok
I played threes every day for like 5
years that's stunning I don't even think
about it it's just part of my life right
right of course I was gonna say the
witness I think could be a good one I
guess that is a similar roadblock right
you have to have a PlayStation 4 PC
I don't yeah that's on Xbox I think so
there's books now but I think that's a
pretty good one to go with actually I've
been wanting to show my mom in
particularly that because I think she'll
get very into it because I I don't know
like they're like you do have to
understand how to like control a
character in a video game world right
with like control sticks and like ones
adjusting camera ones adjusting movement
but I think those puzzles are like just
because you play a lot of games doesn't
mean the puzzles are going to be any
easier doesn't mean they're gonna be
quicker for you to pick up it's still
everyone starts at that same level and
it is really satisfying to explore that
world and do a lot of those puzzles yeah
that's a good one I've seen people talk
about overcooked being a good one
personally I would get way too heated
playing overcoat with someone who didn't
play video games because I already get
pretty heated with people playing
overcooked but a lot of people talk
about playing with like their boyfriend
or girlfriend or whatever and having a
nice time so if that's if you're not I
guess a piece of [ __ ] like I am it might
be good if your communication skills are
above like Stella then overcooked is the
one for you well anyway uh let's do one
more question here before I wrap it up I
think I'm gonna do this one from Robert
J on discord as well after hearing about
Tim's blood-borne platinum trophy what
are some of your proudest achievements
or moments in games I think we've had a
similar question with this before
actually at one point yeah we got this
last week or like being jealous of
someone else's achievement mhm
oh yeah we did well maybe we can just
say something quickly and then we can do
one more after that because I was gonna
say mine is I got the second row a
thousand gamerscore on that which was
nice and then I maxed I got all of them
in modern warfare one which I was very
proud of because the mile-high club on
veteran was a pain in the ass was an
absolute pain in the ass I gotta watch
that at some point slight tangent didn't
they tease something for Sakura like a
while ago and it hasn't come out yet
thanks I'll remember was it just like a
bunch of wallpapers I remember seeing
something that they release are you
thinking of ghosts of Tsushima no it's
okay it was definitely Sakura huh I'm
trying to think it's before the age of
achievements but beating middle your
solid to on extreme back in the day was
I think my greatest achievement not
being great overall but like because
that is absurd I you end up fighting
like 40 Metal Gear rays or something it
is just bonkers how much they dial that
game up I would say every battle real
win I've ever gotten yeah yeah it was
pretty damn good Jake do you heard that
day I got three chicken dinners in one
day
and luck I feel like getting wins in pub
G is very different than getting wins
and other games because not only were
you fighting against other players
you're also fighting against like the
jank of that game as you were playing it
and there are also low ends too nice
no we got one at the end of the day I
remember I think they were too silly to
say we've got one at the end of the day
that was ridiculous I would also say
that as a child I was able to fully
mentally map out banjo kazooie and I
would just tell my mom where all the
collectables were that is good okay
again your mom would be very proud of
you for that I'm very proud so I have
all the achievements in Mass Effect 2
because I've played that game like six
times but I'm also really proud of
having the worst play of the game and
overwatch that me or any of my friends
have ever seen I remember I've talked
about this before but it's unrealistic
route 66 I'm playing a soldier I run
into a skirmish die get rezzed by mercy
and then I just miss all of my shots and
then I hit I accidentally hit the fara
who is mid alt and killed her and so I
got and play the game did a shutdown and
it's awful and there is a clip of it
online somewhere I think our friend
posted it on his YouTube and it's just
everyone laughing at me that's all I'm
most proud of
nice Kelly do you read this last
question yes hey after dark crew I
wanted to try something at your
discretion of course I want to thank you
for keeping this going during this crazy
time and hope you are well in doing your
best to keep your sanity as you are
helping me keep some semblance of
normalcy you all remind me of my group
of friends from college that we just
hang out and drink and talk about all
that are things so one of the things we
do from time to time is go through
hypotheticals from a famous humorist of
ours a favorite humorist of ours Chuck
Klosterman
here goes you're offered a brain pill if
you swallow this pill you will become
10% more intelligent than you currently
are you will be more adept at reading
comprehension logic and could
thinking however to all other people you
know and to all future people you meet
you will seem 20% less intelligent in
other words you will immediately become
smarter but the rest of the world will
perceive you with dumber and there is no
way you can ever alter the universality
of that perception do you take this pill
thanks again for all you do take care
well column from Des Moines Iowa no I
don't know of course not
yeah no I would take the opposite pill I
would take the offset if no one's gonna
take you seriously
you'd be yeah you'd be 10% better it's
solving math equation it would be for
your own personal enrichment right but
at the same time if you were going to
try to contribute anything to science no
one would ever approve your I mean it
depends how many parties are and to
anything so anything humans are social
everything pretty much humans do in
terms of behavior is in order to
increase their standing Oh Jake's
computer is on fire now it's been on too
long
Oh time to wrap up this podcast yeah
nope ale please
I'm perfectly happy with my level of
intelligence wait really crazy really
quickly as Lisa Simpson says as
intelligence goes up happiness often
goes down I thought you're good I think
I say as Lisa Simpson one says like you
know anyway that's been episode 35 of
GameSpot after dark thank you so much
for tuning in and sticking with us
during this strange time I hope you all
are doing well and staying safe and
staying healthy make sure to check out
GameSpot calm and of course go check out
min max see what they're doing over
there they're doing a lot of great stuff
there's a lot much been do you have any
plug other plugs you want to share yeah
coming up the min max show podcast is
her main podcast super fun we talked
about the Mario games we've ranked the
3d Mario game
with David Simms from the blank check
podcast if you listen to that film
podcast I was fun having him on and then
this Friday on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash min max show we're
launching a new show we're reviewing
screenshots from the community called
photo mode snap that I'm very excited
about Callie what about you well you can
find me on twitter at inky doge eco i
nky do ji kko
and yeah please watch those pokemon
videos the explains please watch them
and then on top of that please check out
we've been hard at work at GameSpot on
Animal Crossing guys I'm really proud of
them I've I've done a lot of work for
them so if you if they I guess I mean
they're doing well so it's not like the
Pokemon videos where I'm like begging
you to please watch them but if they've
if you found them helpful or if you find
anything that is missing please let me
know either way and I'll get on that and
please check out the final review
because the review could use more views
actually thank you and Lucy I'm on
Twitter at Lisa James games and I've
actually been working on a new thing so
given the weird time that were all
living in annoyingly I was working on
this and then John Krasinski made one
but it's like it's a kind of a good news
show we kind of have a working title of
good news gaming it should be up by the
time this podcast goes out but it's kind
of highlighting just some feel-good news
stories about gaming that maybe got lost
in the shuffle cuz everyone is obviously
preoccupied with what's going on the
world and that's you know it's super
important that everyone stays informed
but there's a lot of cool stuff
happening still that we wanted to
highlight so look out for that Dave did
an amazing episode of loadout that's
live about how the BFG originally
started as a toy that the guys had I'd
found in a Toys R Us it's really cool
next week Kurt is doing an episode of
remember when shot from his house and it
looks amazing about that random resident
song from the jewel shock vision and the
crazy story behind that and also because
my my team's been doing a lot recently
and for some reason it's all coming out
at once
we shot audio logs last year with so
Jamison from Atlas the character
designer on persona 5 and / 75 royal all
about the new character Kasumi and
that's finally going up maybe it's
already going up we're just in final
negotiations on it let's say all space
is a lie check out please be excited and
you can find me at jacob tech and if you
want to get into this discord please let
us know we've got about 50 or so people
in so far we're not letting we're not
putting the link out there so anyone can
join quite yet we're just trying to like
gauge who's interested in getting them
mostly like listeners the podcast people
who tuned in to the live streams and
whatnot in their first and just kind of
see what it's like see how people are -
people who are thinking of it but anyway
that's all we've got
that's that on that
[Music]